okay so it is 2 30 in the morning
literally half an hour after this show
finished
and i can't sleep otherwise i would have
just done this video later um and i need
to start getting the episodes early like
everybody else right because literally i
have to watch the show and then try to
crank out easter egg videos the reality
is that this episode it was it was cool
in terms of information it didn't really
have a whole lot going for it in terms
of like major easter eggs or anything
however as far as i can tell there are
four major things to come out of this
one of them is a reference to the
juggernaut so here's the thing about
this uh when it comes to
to this episode in particular i guess
the biggest thing to really talk about
is basically anton mogart right so like
midnight man uh this guy's old school
right like the original moon night
series issue number three he was created
by doug mink uh he was cool kind of i
guess so for like 22 days this guy stole
art like valuable pieces of art and
antiquities and stuff like that
for like you know at like the stroke of
midnight and that's where he got like
the midnight midnight man name from um
he was kind of an on-again off-again
villain for uh for mark spector and in
fact there was actually a point when
mark spector basically took him under
his wing and trained him and then
basically midnight man died of cancer
and then ultimately mark spector trained
his son jeff wilde who ultimately just
went by the name midnight uh but
midnight man was not an overly important
character so think of him as something
akin to like the appearance of
swordmaster in the hawkeye series like
it's cool he's there um but obviously of
course because the actor himself has
passed away they're not really going to
be able to do a whole lot with it
but it is a cool concept to see right a
nice little nod to that whole thing the
next big thing to come out of this and
this is really one that i think a lot of
people are are curious about uh and it's
really kind of like two and three that
sort of go hand in hand is jake lockley
right because there are these instances
over the course of the episode where
like mark spector blacks out and then he
wakes up and things have totally changed
right so like when he's dealing with
those three guys that are you know
attacking him that like he wakes up and
like he's got his knife in one of them
and they're about to fall off the cliff
side a lot of people are pointing to the
idea of it being jake lockley that's
possible but one thing that i do want to
point out here and it is something that
looks like the show has changed but one
thing that i do want to point out here
when it comes to moon knight in marvel
comics is that each one of the versions
you see is their own personality so moon
knight is his own personality and mr
knight is his own personality steve
grant jake lockley mark spector they are
all their own personalities whereas in
the show moon knight is basically the
answer to like what happens when mark
spector just puts on a costume and then
goes forward like literally in this
episode he is moon knight and he's
talking to layla like having a
conversation with her and like she
refers to him and he's just kind of like
okay like i can buy you some time and
stuff like that um if it was like the
comics he would have his own personality
so he would have just answered totally
different uh so they are obviously
switching things around and this is what
has given credence to this idea
that as far as
the the potential of it being jake
lockley that they just switched this
character around because in reality in
the comics i mean jake lockley he's a
guy that keeps his ear to the ground
he's like the marvel comics version of
batman's alter ego matches malone he's
just a guy who keeps his ear to the
ground and then uses his access through
various
people that he knows and networking as a
cab driver in order to like learn what's
going on on the street level i mean over
the years in marvel comics it was really
more of like a depiction as opposed to
an outright statement jake lockley was
more of like a brawler type guy um in
moon knight vol 7 they established that
he's more of like a violent brawler but
basically he's not nearly as capable as
like mark specter is in terms of
physical hand-to-hand combat but again
they could just be switching that up so
that what jake lockley ends up being is
just a much darker more sadistic version
of mark spector and in fact this may
very well be a clue that we got when we
had this conversation or that moment in
the in the show when you have arthur
harrow talking directly to konchu when
he's in the little stone statue and he
says like i'm not gonna lie i took
pleasure in harming other people in your
name and it could be that like that's
jake lockley that jake lockley is almost
exactly like arthur harrow is in the
sense that like jake lockley takes
pleasure in hurting people and very
rarely does this personality ever come
out for any number of reasons again we
don't know much about his character
because we haven't really seen him so at
this point it's really just anybody's
guess but i feel like that was an
important thing that needed to be
brought in but again having said that
yeah it could very well just be jake
lockley here but i thought it would have
been kind of cool if mark specter i'm
sorry if moon knight was his own
personality but i could certainly see
how that would be a little bit too much
because even now only four episodes are
only uh three episodes in we are
contending with this issue where you
have uh steve grant and you have mark
spector now there's this potential third
personality and just based on steve
grant and mark spector the plate is
feeling a little full so like if they
started adding in like three more
personalities in addition to those two
it could really make the show unwieldy
and we've all seen how far these limits
can be pushed with like legion
people could only handle that so far
and there's a very fine line between
people being very curious about what's
happening and people being very
frustrated about the situation and not
being able to keep track of everything
so it's probably a smart move that they
didn't really have mr knight as his own
personality and moon knight is his own
personality and instead just made mr
knight the result of what happens when
steve grant becomes moon knight and then
turn the traditional moon knight into
what happens when mark spector becomes
moon knight um and this leads us into
what i think is probably one of the
bigger things here it's really more of
an easter egg as opposed to like you
know them setting up anything in
particular but what they're basically at
least what they borrowed from here is
the octescence so in marvel comics
traditionally the avatars of the various
uh egyptian gods out there they don't
exist uh the only real instance of that
happening is kind of like the sun god
right like his thing but that was only
really a temporary thing uh mark spector
being the avatar of konshu is the only
real instance when any of the any ad
have had like an ongoing avatar or even
series of avatars on earth that have
basically done their bidding the only
exception to that which is kind of a
loose exception and you could call it a
reach if you could really call anything
a reach when you're dealing with a comic
book tv show or even comic book movies
um is like the black panthers right
because they're basically the earthly
avatars of best and depending on what
the mcu ends up doing with spider-man
you could very well see a circumstance
where like peter parker tom holland is
like the earthly avatar of some spider
totem out there i still stick by the
idea that he's like some variation maybe
like the scion or something like that i
don't really know but the important
thing here is that you never really see
that in the comics but there is an
instance where that does take place and
it does pertain to gods so in marvel
comics you have a group of beings that
are known as balthack sidorak ferala
icon watum valthar ragador and
the last one always is kraken that's
that's the that last one always throws
me for a loop right uh but that group is
known as the octescence now the idea
behind the octescence even though
they're they are in no way tied to the
egyptian gods is that they all had
earthly avatars that over time ended up
basically
capturing these particular artifacts
what you had in marvel comics was an
event called the eighth day which was an
amazing story where juggernaut was just
ridiculously op uh but the whole point
behind this is that each one of these
guys each one of the members of the
octessan's basically created an artifact
that resided on earth much in the same
way that you have the scarab that is
being being used currently by arthur
harrow in moon knight or potentially
even the suit of moon knight that's
being used which of course belonged to
konchu but the way this worked when it
came to the octessens is that the the
first object that was picked up was of
course the crimson gem of sidorak which
was accessed by kane marco who became
the juggernaut when that happened it
kicked off the eighth day event and what
it did is it led to these other
individuals in fact seven other
individuals just being arbitrarily drawn
to each one of these artifacts that were
left behind by the octesans the whole
reason why this was done was because
this group was basically engaging in a
wager which one of them was the
strongest and so when the first artifact
was picked up by kane marco and then the
other artifacts were picked up basically
those avatars would each lead one-eighth
of the earth's population and then they
would go to war with each other and
whichever avatar and their
human
group whatever it is servants if you
want to call them that whichever one
came out on top that would prove which
member of the octescence was the most
powerful so because of the fact that
that juggernaut had the crimson gem of
sidorak if he had basically won this war
then it would have shown sidorak was the
most powerful ultimately that never came
to fruition and things just kind of
continued on as normal but with the
octessans each leaving behind a little
artifact that belonged to them that
people could in turn use to harness a
portion of their power that's basically
what you see happening in moon night
that the suit of moon knight was created
by uh created by konchu himself and
given to moonlight that's his artifact
on earth which belongs to his avatar the
scarab that arthur harrow has in his
possession is seemingly the scarab of
ahmed which in turn is the artifact she
left on earth in order to
give to her avatar which will ultimately
end up being arthur harrow at the end of
all this so again you know it's a cool
little reference there again whether or
not i think anything big is going to
come out of that i don't really know and
by no means do i think that what's going
on with like the various hosts of the
inead of like horus and all those guys i
don't think that like they're going to
war against each other it would just
seem weird
and unnecessary it's just they're
earthly avatars that speak for them on
earth and that's basically it uh but it
is a cool little easter egg having said
that as far as the ending goes
uh i mean
not a whole lot to explain here mark
spector and layla are on the hunt to
stop arthur harrow
and that's basically it uh not a whole
lot to explain it really and what was
really kind of interesting about this
ending is that it just kind of happened
it was just kind of there it didn't
really leave us as far as i'm aware on
any kind of cliffhanger in terms of like
the third personality right it's not as
though it was something where like uh
steve grant or mark spector switches to
the third personality which looks at
itself in the mirror and they look just
slightly different than like steve grant
or mark spector it's just kind of that
version of himself looking at him and
then it's like okay
so that's the third personality and then
you're just waiting for the name to drop
and we never get it right but like that
would have been a cool way to end the
episode we didn't really get that uh
instead it was literally just arthur
harrow talking to kanchu and just being
like just so you know bro uh you're the
reason i'm doing this you know that kind
of a thing so like the mistakes of
conscious coming back to visit him that
kind of a thing um one thing that i will
say i was kind of disappointed about
is i was really hoping to see bass i
didn't fully expect to see that happen
because while bass initially started off
as an egyptian god again bast eventually
ended up becoming a a wakandan god i
guess god goddess i mean do genders
really matter when it comes to gods
they can appear in any form they want to
um so i guess it doesn't really matter
in that particular instance but i was
kind of hoping to see bass again it
makes sense that we didn't but it would
have been a cool reference at the very
least if at some point in time which i
was kind of expecting it over the course
of this episode we get this kind of
discussion on maybe like the history of
the any ad or something like that
because that's kind of par for the
course when it comes to mcu tv shows
that you end up getting like the first
two episodes which set the stage you get
the third episode which explains
everything and they wrap it all up over
the last two and that's basically it um
we didn't necessarily get that in this
and i was kind of hoping that we would
because then even if we don't
necessarily get bass as part of the any
ad they would just be like once upon a
time bass hung out with us and then she
went to the cool kids table
the end and like that would be it there
really wouldn't be a whole lot more you
know more to give us than that but we
didn't get that and again it's not the
end of the world i don't think it takes
away from the episode i thought it was
fun but it was a fun cool episode i do
like the tension that's going on between
layla and mark spector um i think at the
end of the day the reality of the
situation is going to come out i mean i
think that that tension that's being
built up there is would resonate more
with like non-comic book readers or
people who are unfamiliar with the
history of moon knight and kind of
piecing that stuff together on their own
instead of referencing the source
material if you read the comics like you
know that like layla is a stand-in for
marlene and that layla's father being
like the architect uh i'm sorry the
archaeologist was likely killed by raw
bushmen whether we'll see royal bushman
i don't know i think if we end up seeing
him it'll be as like the very tail end
of the last episode and it's like to be
continued in moon knight season two
right like the guy who like [ __ ] over
mark spector and left him for dead like
that sounds like something they would do
that they would kind of make rob bushman
the main villain for for season two and
we would get more of that story there uh
but the reality is assuming they go with
the original comic book origin for mark
spector that he was basically a
mercenary that was along for the ride
with marlene and her father and then
raul buschmann and those guys and then
ultimately raul bushman just shot
everybody up except for marlene left him
for dead left mark spector for dead and
then of course mark spectre ended up
becoming the avatar of conscious on
earth when his body was taken to the
base of konchu's statue so again it's
just one of those things where they may
switch it up i mean they're kind of
changing a few things here and there
don't really see a reason why they would
change his origin and i think at this
point in the show if they were going to
give us raw bushmen they would have done
it already and it makes sense that they
haven't because there's enough going on
as it is we don't need a secondary
villain it would over complicate things
and it would take away from what is
otherwise a a pretty simple and easy to
follow series that also has a good blend
of action and stuff like that in it so
uh with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this to an end let me know what
you guys think down in the comments
section of this episode i mean is moon
knight slower than the other mcu shows
yeah absolutely and and
if i'm being honest with you guys
i'd say it's probably the weakest of the
shows to be quite honest i mean i won't
really know until we get to the end of
it because as you guys know when it
comes to mcu shows things just pop off
at the very end right the same thing
happened with wanda vision it took one
division like three or four episodes to
get good and it was nine episodes long
right and maybe we could even say longer
than that maybe like five or six before
the show really started to take off so
it's kind of the standard right that
like they save all the all the best
bangs and all the best explosions for
the end of the show uh maybe that's what
they're doing here but as it stands
right now you know if we're going like
pound for pound all things being equal
uh i would rank it like loki uh wand
division
this show and then hawkeye it's just
kind of the weakest of them of them so
far not really a shot against it just in
terms of like interest intrigue that
kind of a thing it's a slow burn but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this to an end uh we're saying
that twice
[Laughter]
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace